the movie opens with a scene where John
and Tom FBI agents are at a harbor in
San Francisco John starts to smoke a
cigarette to Tom's surprise he never
does
he asks John if his wife knows he smokes
John acts cool but then Tom assures him
that he will not tell his wife by now
they knew that they had been tipped off
as the enemy had their guard up John
counted about five to six shooters
they decided to take a look with their
guns out both of them proceeded to check
the area John informs Tom about a backup
while checking on a bullet outside a
Cabin John realizes that the bullet
belonged to an assassin and right then
Tom shoots at the enemy beware of their
presence the men and the two FBI agents
exchange bullets
John gets shot in the arm by the
Assassin he tried warning Tom about
as Rogue tries to shoot Jon again Tom
opens fire at him Tom shoots him in the
face as Rogue falls into the sea they
assume that there was no chance of Rogue
surviving John knowing how skillful the
Assassin was does not believe Tom but
lets it Go backup arrives and the scene
changes to Tom with his family Diane
Tom's wife tells him to warn Jon not to
smoke in front of the kids while he was
on the phone with John
as the call ends a car stops outside
Tom's residence and a man climbs out of
it unaware of the suspicious man Tom is
in the bathroom when his wife screams
get his attention he gets shot in the
face and is thrown against a door where
his wife and daughter were trying to
hide they both get shot and Tom screams
as John and his wife were making their
way to Tom's house they saw fire
brigades and police officers outside the
residence
hurriedly John runs towards the house
the officer in charge tries to stop him
but then as Jon shows his badge he
informs him about the casualties unable
to believe it John gasps for air he
makes his way inside the house to check
for Clues and finds the same bullet he
found at the harbor
by connecting the dots he's convinced
that Rogue was still alive and killed
his friend and his family the scene
changes to a club in the Yakuza District
a man exiting a silver car is seen
entering the club
the man makes his way past all the
people on the Dance Floor he skillfully
kills the men guarding the private booth
and makes his way in
a room full of Japanese Yakuza can be
seen having fun and smoking cigarettes
the guy shoots a Yakuza member who seems
to be having fun with a prostitute the
gunfire alerts the men inside the room
as the cameras go off the Japanese
Yakuza sends his dogs to check and they
go silent the man stands at the end of
the hallway and they open fire
thinking they killed him the leader
sends one of them to check
the man does not return but one of the
dogs does with the bomb around his neck
the bomb goes off and everyone in there
gets killed
Rogue enters the room where the Yakuza
questions him on his betrayal and Rogue
shoots himself instead the FBI enters
the club in the next scene with Jon
leading the investigation John finds the
same bullet as he did in Tom's house
the scene changes to Jon getting a call
from Jenny she asks if he was still
going to attend Danielle's first
basketball game
he informs his wife on how they found
the guy after so many years
he also tells her that this time he
won't let him go Jenny tells him how
this case had cost him his relationship
and not to ruin it with his son
the scene changes to the FBI office
where goey the new team member is
introduced to the rest
John updates everybody on Rogue and his
recent activities the police are
confused about Rogue changing sides
three years ago he worked for the
yanagawa John informs them about both
yanagawas and the Chang Shiro yanagawa
killed Chang's family years ago stealing
and selling everything from the clan
leaving two statues of horses
Shiro looking for a buyer could start a
war between them
they decided to keep an eye on both
Clans the scene changes to Rogue inside
his apartment getting ready he enters
the Chang's estate where a union is set
between the two after he killed the
Shiro's men
still skeptical Chang questions Rogue on
his loyalty to which he replies that he
has no master and he serves whomever
he informs Lee about the arrival of the
horses which makes him happy
Chang introduces two of his men to Rogue
the T Brothers whom Chang warns to keep
an eye on Rogue in Japan Shiro is seen
having a sword fight with a member of
the clan Kira Shiro's daughter informs
him about the horse being shipped out to
San Francisco
he asks his daughter to go as well to
keep things in check she assures him of
doing her best and leaves for America
the scene changes to Chinatown San
Francisco where John is seen walking
into a clubhouse to see a guy named
Benny as soon as they enter a room Benny
drops the act and informs John about his
findings
the person who had made rogue's bullets
had been killed last week a plastic
surgeon who might have operated on Rogue
was found in his kitchen killed
another friend of the Doctor Who
presumably might have helped with the
surgery was found dead Benny informs
John about the last surgeon but that he
might be hiding John asks him to contact
him when he finds him
the scene changes to a harbor where the
tea Brothers meet Rogue and their
contact Rogue hands woo the older
brother an envelope trucks are being
loaded with fancy cars by the Japanese
Yakuza and the horses are said to be in
one of the cars
the trucks along with their guard leave
the harbor but then are surrounded by
the police
already aware of the procedures they
tell the officer about the already made
arrangements they obey when the officer
doesn't budge and get out of their cars
the Yakuza asks for the officer's
captains who turn out to be Woo's
contact the guys are shot at the harbor
and the truck with the horses is taken
by Rogue to Chang's Warehouse Wu
confirms the presence of the horses
Chang Awards Rogue with money and a girl
the FBI arrives at the harbor John
checks the site with his team and
concludes that whatever was stolen was
big
John and his teammates are seen driving
to a cafe where the officer is found and
beaten up by him he asks about him about
who was behind it but the officer gets
shot by Rogue finding his position John
orders his team to circle around as he
chases Rogue unfortunately he loses him
the scene changes to Kira Shiro's
daughter Landing in America and taking
over the operation Rogue is seen calling
Jon from his apartment he informs him of
the shipment and tells him to meet him
there
upon arrival John is surprised to see
Chang and Wu outside of the warehouse
when he asks them to open the warehouse
John sees Rogue he finds out that his
identity is now Victor Shaw John also
tells him that whatever he had done the
surgeon couldn't change his eyes and
that he recognized him through them
John lashes out at him by asking him
about how he killed his partner and his
family
upon searching the area his team finds
nothing but Jon seems to recognize Rogue
impressed by his contacts Chang now
trusts Rogue even more unaware of the
fact that Rogue was responsible for
tipping the cops
Chang asks Rogue to stay at his house to
keep an eye on things
John is seen practicing his shooting
while Rogue stares at Chang's wife and
daughter through a window the scene
changes to Chang's daughter being
playful with Rogue to which his wife
warns him not to come between her and
her family
Wu enters as soon as Mrs Chang leaves
and tells Rogue about how he still
doesn't trust him
he informs him on how he's responsible
for running things around here the scene
changes to the aggressive tea Brothers
in the Triad District a biker presumably
from the Yakuza Clan provokes him and
his friends chasing him Rogue brings
them to the Yakuza bikes fists are
exchanged and amongst the fight rogue
kills Wu's brother with a katana
the FBI reached the scene in the morning
where they conclude that the katana the
Shiro trademark had killed him and this
could start a war John orders his men to
stake out at a famous Yakuza place in
case
the scene changes to Wu informing Chang
about the incident with his brother
Chang tells him to lay low to which Wu
is furious
adding fuel to the fire Rogue provokes
Wu by commenting that a man should never
give up his honor or his family and tips
him towards a Yakuza Club The sayu Tea
House
the shootout breaks out in the tea house
later where Wu orders his men to kill
everyone
one of Shiro's really close henchmen is
there goey informs Jon about the
commotion on his arrival both the Yakuza
and Wu's men are killed
Terry is also killed by one of the
bullets fired by the men Jon spots Rogue
in a building which he chases after him
but ends up losing him again the scene
changes when Rogue informs Chang about
Wu and his men making a scene at the Tea
House
Chang is furious but is left with no
option
Rogue is at Kira's office where she
informs him that her father was very
pleased with him she tells him about how
her father's next order was to kill
Chang along with his wife and his child
she assigns two men with him for
Assurance Jon is with his wife who is
not happy about the men stationed
outside their house worried about what
Jon had gotten them into she felt sorry
for him
she tells him how his work ruined their
marriage afraid of them turning out like
Tom and his family Benny calls John and
informs him about the surgeon in Mexico
the surgeon hesitant at first does not
want to tell them
he's afraid that Rogue might find him
just like they had others he tells them
how Rogue resembles someone who was
working for the FBI
he also tells them how he had changed
his bone structure and voice the scene
changes to men entering Chang's House
he seems to be sending his wife
somewhere
when in his office Wu shoots at him
Rogue comes in and shoots at both Wu and
Chang he seems to have killed both his
wife and children as ordered but he
kills the skilled Fighters that were
waiting outside
Rogue is then seen escorting Chang's
wife and daughter into a car the scene
changes to the FBI receiving pictures of
Rogue fighting the Yakuza and escorting
Chang's wife and daughter
Cheryl arrives in America and John
visits him with a file containing
pictures of rogue rogue enters the
Yakuza warehouse and Shiro welcomes him
with open arms
he presents the horses to Shiro Who as a
reward gives him a briefcase
the briefcase holds the file alongside
money Shiro's men hold guns against his
head and ask men to question Rogue about
Chang's wife and child
just as rogue kills both men Shiro
notices the fake horses
the suitcase blows up as soon as Shiro
leaves the glass office killing most of
his men
Rogue and Shiro fight with katanas as he
questioned Shiro about the incident
three years ago
Rogue finds out that the man who had
tipped them off was none other than John
Furious rogue kills Shiro and contacts
Jon to meet up with him at the harbor
John informs Geo for backup positioned
in place John searched the area for
rogue they get into a fist fight where
Rogue questions Jon about the incident
not believing him Tom tells him to look
him in the eyes as they were the only
things surgeons could not change guilty
John tells everything to Tom about how
he tried to get out he is said that he
had told the Yakuza about him but he
thought that they would just scare him
John is Shut by Geo on accident when he
was trying to aim for rogue the movie
ends with Chang's wife receiving one of
the horses and Kira Shiro's daughter
receiving her father's head and Tom
drives off in his silver car